New York Post reports Florida Yanks two
billion dollars from woke BlackRock over
social engineering project
crazy Florida said Thursday that has
begun to divest two billion dollars in
funds overseen by BlackRock a sharp
rebuke of the giant asset managers
investing policies under CEO Larry Larry
Fink that right-leaning critics have
blasted as woke capitalism the
divestment under DeSantis the largest of
its kind by an individual state is the
latest sign of mounting unrest among
Republican policymakers over so-called
ESG
what do you guys think DeSantis is
running good news victory in the culture
I hope he does because who else is there
Donald Trump and Kanye West I mean you
guys got to prove yourself to me if you
either one of you guys wants to be
president because DeSantis is leading
the charge let me just say this I'm
Prime Time 99 I'm a pimp on a blimp I
was at Mar-A-Lago I was uh you know
lucky enough to be there because you
know I'm Prime on the ground all the
time but yeah The Vibes were a little
weird in the sense that like you know it
was kind of like the graveyard of 2020
so it was kind of sad you know and
everybody's grasping for that energy of
2016 and it just wasn't necessarily
there and I remember this is what Trump
would always say it would always say
before he ran to be like I can just be
it more I suck at impersonations but
he'd just be like I could just be admira
logo you know with my beautiful wife
Melanie and I don't need any of this and
he said that again and the second time
he said that in the speech I felt it I'm
like dude you don't need this again you
know I understand that you were robbed
and that's how you feel and that's why
you want to you know come back but in
the Vengeance story will be epic and I
hope that if he runs I hope he wins
personally but I'm just saying it's like
why why do that when you just anything
any outcome in my personal opinion when
you're his age I believe he's 78 years
old yeah yep
on vacation Bud go to DC is a hell hole
I was
I was freaking child Predators Bill
Clinton type people I mean oh my gosh I
wouldn't I couldn't imagine the people
that live in Washington that have a
freaking you know uh humiliation fetish
I believe I hear they drink a lot
is the biggest party town in the country
you have to be on fentanyl it's so bad
now party is one way to put it oh and
did you say that I don't think it's
drinking culture in the country or in
the cities I was talking about but this
is how bad DC is I want to bring up this
point I don't know if you saw McPherson
Square which is 0.2 miles from the White
House Tent City yeah yeah saw that video
last night like what didn't he make
sense what are you doing within City
this is I don't know Tin City
divesting from BlackRock I mean we've
been complaining about BlackRock for a
while I think Ian was the first person
to bring it up that State Street
BlackRock and who's the other one
Vanguard oh yeah they they all have
pieces of other companies and each other
so nuts it's so crazy it's collectively
they own like 19 of almost every
publicly traded company it's a wild man
and uh I I like this divestment because
I'm really concerned about Black Stone I
believe it's Black Stone buying property
it's one of black rocks it's like a an
offshoot I think black rock is an
offshoot of Black Stone it's one or the
other well that's the biggest problem in
society it's like there's no middle
class because nobody can afford to buy a
home because all the single family homes
are artificially inflated by these
companies like BlackRock that have such
big portfolios if the you know real
price of the property you had to pay the
cash price or couldn't get these easy
loans if they weren't able to
artificially inflate the value of these
homes in a single-family home could be
affordable but it's not because of these
companies yes black black stone I'm help
me out in the chat if you know which one
of the two companies it is but what
they're doing is essentially buying
property and holding it hostage for the
loss they'll print more money if they
need more money to stay solvent they use
investor funds to say solvent and they
just wait and they'll put put on the
market if you can't afford it you can't
afford it they don't they don't even
live in there exactly that's no we
shouldn't have yeah we shouldn't have
mega corpse owning property yeah but the
worst thing is Bill Gates owns the most
farmland and he's not going to farm on
it because of uh climate change well he
is but if you're going to be soy and
it's going to be corn but to clarify
he's the largest individual owner of
Farmland but he doesn't own the most
what about how much land China owns them
absolutely what's the point of that I
mean that doesn't seem right thousands
of acres in Florida for experiments on
monkeys did you hear that I'm an animal
lover no that's terrible yeah it's tough
there was a that neuraling story from
Elon Musk came out and and this is why
in the conservative side we're like oh
Elon Musk is our hero but he's literally
a transhumanist that wants to put a chip
in your brain so you can park your Tesla
potentially so I mean I mean come on
that seems and I'm not even hating on
you Elon good for you but it's just he's
not he's not exactly our hero I hope he
is I think we don't want to park your
Tesla with your brain and if I could
live forever uh uh you know would you if
you could right now if first you know
because you're a wealthy young man they
say oh you can live forever Tim but no
we're gonna plug into this can be your
Consciousness into this computer you're
gonna live forever being young until you
die is is is like sounds like a good
idea like having the body of a of a 24
year old but you'll still die when
you're 78 or whatever you know you don't
live forever living forever I was
watching this thing about living forever
and they and it was saying that if you
remained young you'd never want to die
it's only that when you get older you're
tired you start getting more and more
pain and you're like okay I'm ready to
go this is too much for me but if you
were in a young body you'd be like no
I'm great it's like you're here with
Jared Kushner just said that yeah I mean
Jared Kushner he's gonna live forever
he's taking care of his health right now
because he plans on living forever
imagine if women could have babies until
they were like 300 if they just their
system is just a lot of babies yeah
they'll be good for them for the
population regrowth if we need that if
we can expand you know fertility ages
and stuff which we probably can I forgot
why I brought up Tesla but it doesn't
matter because the point you made is a
lot better than the point Elon made you
said that he wants to put a chip in your
brain so you can park your Tesla which
is is more likely to be what really
happens whereas he was like if you're if
you're paralyzed and your your spine is
broken we can make you walk again and if
you're blind even if you've never seen
in your life we can stimulate the visual
cortex and it's like it sounds really
really awesome but in reality people are
going to get and they're going to park
their Teslas yeah he just announced yeah
so go ahead we have we have these
devices in our pockets that grant us
access to the summation of human
knowledge and we we use them to look at
pictures of cats and argue with
strangers and he wants to make that time
the reaction time of operation as you
know as quick as possible because right
now I think he always talks about the
milliseconds that it is the reaction
time but he wants to make it so it's
just you know simultaneous thought
action you know transhuman you are a
cyborg cyberkinetic connected cyber
kinetically connected to your device
well he just announced human trials that
are going to be get be uh beginning in
in a few months where humans are going
to be implanted with a microchip inside
of their head and he even made a
statement saying that I could have one
right now no one would even know because
I got to make this point too let me tell
you this is the problem with artificial
intelligence even the biggest
telecommunication companies from a t to
Verizon they have uh programmers people
that try to work on this every day
artificial intelligence so that when you
call in let's say you want to talk to
customer service and you talk to a robot
that tries to convince a human that it's
actually a robot and overwhelmingly
99.99999
in person people realize that they are
talking to a robot so they cannot even
artificially recreate a conversation
with a robot non-person so the idea that
we can just like artificially create
another human that's insane but they can
use algorithmic technology to basically
you know like use you know guessing you
know whatever you know simulated guess
exactly Elon said he's going to get the
chip I think uh in that in that reveal
he's like yeah I'll be I think he was
indicating he'll be getting it and I
think he'll the first tweet it was from
it'll be Elon will be the first one that
tweets from his brand it'll say his
tweet and it'll say you know it says
tweet from iPhone it'll say like from
iPhone or from it'll say from Elon
musk's brain and you know what the Tweet
will say the actual text uh yes hello
world oh that's a good one or a great
part or I'm rooting for brain I am death
because what is it a timer I'm imagining
he's on stage and he's like he pulls his
hair up and shows you the scar and he
says I have a neural link chip implanted
and I'm going to show you how it works I
have here my phone it's connected and
and
he's gonna collapse start damn it he's
like I am alive again
I was just saying it was going to sing
his brain and then he was going to
collapse tweeting from his brain look
man the I got self-driving Tesla and it
makes terrible mistakes I wouldn't take
a brain chip maybe in like 20 years but
even then I don't even know about that
well I don't want it I would never tell
you tell me this another selfish plug so
I have a show coming out at the
beginning of the year on The Blaze and
uh the set is going to be a a blimp so
sorry Tim that this is relevant and so I
was thinking about calling it The Mother
blimp and saying that my mom's
Consciousness before she died was
transferred to a computer and then she
actually runs the blimp and then I'm
gonna talk to my dead mom on the show is
that too much a little bit
yeah are you gonna have like a like a
voice a speaker talking to you yes yes
of course is it going to be like a a
voice robotic yes type voice yeah is
that too much is that I mean I'm
definitely watching okay you know
Amazon's attempting to do that to create
to capture people duh you can live with
your grandmother forever
in a computer simulation yeah it does
would you want to do this would I do it
no I mean it's like buying a picture
frame of your you can look at like a
digital picture frame like I'm saying
they want to make a VR where you have
some sort of like you know spirit I
don't know I mean it would feel weird
but it's like a sex doll or something I
wouldn't buy that never have sex with
that so would you do brain link neural
net would I do that are you interested
in it no I would not no that's I think
that's like and I'm not even some super
religious person but that's like the
transhumanist satanic thing now as soon
as you do that you die if you're like
just because oh we're gonna go well I
just I just think that's like the last
come on we we are
humans that have souls you know we're
not like you know we're we're a soul
that has a body we're not a we're not a
thumb that just happens to have a soul
we're a soul that happens to have a
thumb if that makes sense so again we
have some important thing inside of us
so as soon as we like neural connected
we tap into it we lose it I feel like so
that's why it's important that we do die
and that's why I'm almost starting to
believe in almost reincarnation I know
that sounds weird but I feel like and to
go back to my mom rip I miss you so much
but I feel like I see her like she's
around like she's maybe reincarnated
sometimes like I feel her energy Ian
asked earlier if we were in a simulation
and uh I'm fine with that interpretation
but I feel like we I have this
conversation with Sheamus before that
simulation Theory feels like rudimentary
Christianity or like very very
rudimentary religion in general yeah
where it's like if if you're gonna come
and say that you think we live in a
constructed universe made by a higher
like a form of life or something I'm
like sure but there have been people who
have been you know theorizing
hypothesizing and philosophy advising
upon that concept for thousands of years
we just didn't have computers so they
didn't call it a simulation they just
called it God who created the universe
with purpose and reason and created life
so I kind of feel like you know I agree
uh I don't I don't really follow any
organized religion but I do believe
there's a God I do believe in something
akin to a soul I don't know I kind of
feel like the reason I bring it up is
because of what you're saying and then
you asked about simulation it ties back
into how crazy the universe is and me
personally I understand probability I
understand math but you see what's been
going on in news and in the world and it
certainly just does not feel like we're
on this track of Randomness
there's a reason some of the most
powerful people in the world worship
molec and demonic entities and try to
summon them in it's been documented that
there's something else beyond our
physical existence that is there
energetically within uh different
dimensions that we can't quantify and
understand absolutely because the most
important people in our world do do Play
in that realm well don't forget about
Malik I want to go back on it but I mean
the idea that everything came from
nothing that's the same as a tornado
going through a junkyard and creating a
seven you know 47 on the other end it's
just impossible I mean it's just that
you know that's why I know you think
scientifically you know this and that
well look look you know I'm not trying
to dismiss what you're saying I'm just
saying to think about it like the
mechanisms of the universe and the the
organization of free energy is just a
component of the Creator yeah I know and
that's why I think there just has to be
a critter and I don't even want to try
to sound like a Bible banger but they'll
even tell you that like you know if a
trillion monkeys punched you know on a
trillion keyboards that they would be
able to write Shakespeare that's not
possible right so I think Cassandra she
was like have you ever seen a monkey
she's like they'll just poop all over
yeah I mean come on so yeah I think it
is possible in the definition of the
word but that doesn't dismiss that there
could be something creating the order
that we notice you think it's possible
that even if a trillion monkeys were
hitting a trillion at a trillion times
times a trillion seconds you do think
that they could accidentally hit it and
recreate Shakespeare
a trillion is a lot that's what I'm
saying I'm talking a trillion you guys
actually think that a monkey hitting a
keyboard would even with an infant see
with an infinite amount of times I know
in my head even with an infinite
Infinity loop-de-loop they would never
no no I disagree you and I a million Tim
pools times a trillion could never
recreate Shakespeare I just I disagree
trillion times infinity a trillion maybe
but Infinity no because basically what
you're saying is that
with an infinite number of monkeys it's
completely Limitless the iterations of
which they're smashing the key that's
what they're going to tell you
mathematically yes yeah that's the case
the likelihood is so close to zero like
it's point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero
on and on but the logical percentage is
zero and yeah you would say like
realistically it's very unlikely that
that would happen I don't think it's an
accident I don't think that people
accidentally typed up reality as we know
it it seems like this twisting and
turning of gravity and of subatomic
particles is all like uh counter and
interrelated and when you look at the
cosmic microwave background radiation
from The Big Bang this web of energy
that's fluxing through planetoids
beating our hearts I it could be an
accident
you know that always should you know and
that shows us as the center of the
universe and that's why I do I do
believe we are the center but listen
this is what I'm just saying one of the
biggest lies that I believe that is done
on human mankind right now is they want
to make you think that you're just some
sort of cosmic accident that came from
The Big Bang so that you were an atheist
so that you don't have any sort of you
know moral responsibility for your
actions here on Earth and that like your
life doesn't really matter because when
your life doesn't matter you're able to
be indoctrinated and whatever have you
read about near-death experiences yeah
I'm pretty familiar with it yeah I was
reading I read a book where it was just
like they went around asking different
people and they found overwhelmingly
the overwhelming majority experience
very very similar things in very
different circumstances like they
experienced a giant ball of warmth and
love and this feeling of being pulled
towards it and then there are other
people who described things that were
like seemingly random or nonsensical and
so they were like it seems like 80 of
the stories are are very very similar
whether they were in a hospital whether
they were in the street whether they
were in a car accident
the overall majority experience
something very very similar described it
in a very very similar way that there
was this like bright light ball of
energy before them that they were being
drawn towards that felt like warmth and
love it's the sun what's up it's
magnetic yo we live in a magnetic
universe and our souls are magnetic
magnetically derived at pieces of energy
and the Sun is yanking us towards it and
our bodies are anchoring it to the Earth
our bones
but when your bones aren't anchoring it
anymore man your Soul's free to roam
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time